The last time that Valve dropped a VR
headset, the appropriately named Index,
it upended the market overnight,
becoming the standard by which every
other headset was measured. But in the 7
years since its launch, there have been
a ton of exciting innovations in
consumer VR. Big screen made us rethink
boxy generic fits. Many competitors
delivered highquality displays. Meta's
Quest lineup continued to evolve and now
supports robust standalone experiences,
not to mention the flexibility to pair
them with a PC. And all the while, Steam
VR software has received consistent care
and attention, but Valve's hardware team
has been working only behind the scenes.
Thankfully, what they were doing changes
the game again. Not every headline is
going to be positive because in many
ways, the frame does not push VR forward
the way we might have hoped. its
screens, performance, battery weight,
and comfort all fell behind our
expectations and or its competitors. But
just like the Index set the bar for
overall experience that the rest of the
industry chased for years, the way that
the Steam Frame ties everything together
into a complete package is just going to
be really freaking hard to compete with.
Standalone VR that you can take anywhere
without selling your data to Meta,
check. Untethered, highfidelity PC VR,
the likes of which we've never seen
before. That one's a big check. [music]
And the biggest innovation is the one
that's hiding in plain sight. Steam OS.
You've seen it before, but now it's got
a fresh new party trick that allows
games made for Intel and AMD processors
to run on ARM. So, uh, access to
gaming's library of Alexandria. Check.
Well, checkish, actually. More on that
later after I check off this segue to
our sponsor,
>> Threat Locker. If you've been following
the channel for a while now, you've
probably heard of Threat Locker and seen
the cool things we've gotten to work on
with them. If not, they make adopting a
zero trust framework easier for
businesses to navigate. And their
flagship event, Zero Trust World, is
coming up in February. Learn more and
secure your tickets today with the link
below.
My first 30 minutes with the frame,
excitedly unboxing and setting it up are
going to be over on short circuit. So,
I'm not going to be getting into that
here. Instead, I want to focus on using
it. And right out of the box, the Steam
Frame did not have the wow factor that I
was hoping for. It is a solid upgrade
over previous generation headsets. And
Valve's experience shows in the
thoughtful design with a dedicated IPD
adjustment wheel and lock, quick button
access to video pass through or other
bindable functions, a peripheral port
for future upgrades, and an included
spacer to help prevent long lashes from
greasing up the lenses. [music] With
impressive pancake optics, 2160 x 2160
resolution per eye, and up to a 144
hertz refresh rate, the screen door
effect is pretty minimal, and clarity,
both static and in motion, is good. The
issue is that I can think of multiple
headsets that I've worn, some of them
years older than this one, that surpass
it in at least some of those ways. And
guys, I was really hoping that when
Valve told me they were targeting
index-like performance, but wireless,
they specifically meant the latency,
[music] not the orange and blue edge
fringing on moving objects. I do
understand why they went with LCD. Going
to a more responsive technology like
OLED would have hurt battery life or
brightness or both, but it does feel
distinctly last gen in that [music]
regard. And the same goes for the
feeling of immersion. Pancake lenses,
they're thin, they're light, and those
are good things, but they do come with a
bit of blooming in high contrast areas.
And while a 110°ree horizontal field of
view is good, it's not industryleading.
The speakers, for that matter, are sorry
Valve, not as good as the Index. And
while the nose skirt does block most
light and is pretty comfortable, it just
can't compare to a custom gasket. But
it's 2026, not 206. And within the
constraints of current technology, the
[music] Frame is a solid headset, a
sturdy platform from which Valve can
launch their truly standout features.
Let's run through them then in order of
excitingness. Starting, of course, with
wireless streaming from a PC. Guys, this
is easily the most polished experience
that you will have with your Frame. The
included dongle uses the mostly
unoccupied six gigahertz band to deliver
a wireless display experience that, to
put it plainly, knocked me right out of
my chair and into a room scale
experience that was unhindered by
cumbersome wires and tedious base
station setup. And you don't have to use
the dongle. You can actually stream over
your own Wi-Fi. But we found that just
like with the MetaQuest, the Wi-Fi
experience was less consistent and the
dongle was the way to go. But wait,
there's more. Valve actually defaults to
a third operation mode that they are
right to be very proud of. It's called
multilink streaming and it uses both the
dongle and your own Wi-Fi network to
deliver each packet on the lowest
latency path which resulted in a
seamless experience even here in our
interference nightmare of an office
space. Absolutely shocking. But this
raises the question guys. If
highfidelity VR pushes the limits of
even the fastest cables, how can
wireless, even good wireless, possibly
compete? By using the next most exciting
feature, foviated streaming. The idea
here is simple. By tracking your gaze
using two internal high-speed cameras,
Steam VR can [music] give priority to
the part of the scene that you're
actually looking at, streaming that at a
quality that, to my eyes, was
indistinguishable from a wired system.
Then it saves bandwidth by reducing the
bit rate of the stream to any part of
the screen that lands in your peripheral
vision. That sounds terrible, kind of
like uh texture popin, but this article
from Pixelcraft illustrates how the
sharpest part of your vision is actually
only about 1% of your field of view. And
outside of about 8%, clarity drops off a
cliff. So, the theory is more sound than
you'd think. But even then, it still had
the potential to suck. See, your eyes
move from one focal point to another,
literally in the blink of an eye. And if
you shifted from, you know, checking out
an ammo readout to lining up a target,
and you saw any kind of quality shift
every time you did that, it would be
horribly immersionbreaking. But I got to
say, guys, Valve nailed it. It is so
fast that no matter how hard I tried to
look around as quickly as I could, I was
never, not once, able to catch it. This
has to be, and these are not words that
I use lightly, the most magical it just
works experience that I've had in a long
time. And probably it's in the top three
of my entire career covering tech. But
wait, there's more. The third most
exciting feature, especially when
compared to the index, is the frames
standalone functionality. And this is
something that I didn't expect myself to
be saying. I mean, I've publicly worried
many times that by prioritizing
standalone VR, it could mean the death
of PC VR as a whole. But the Steam Frame
has made me feel like that Lionus who
was concerned about that was living in a
horsedrawn world when the automobile was
right over the horizon. To put that
another way, vroom vroom,
I was wrong. fiated rendering, Valve's
ability to push developers to optimize
Steam games, and competent hardware have
turned standalone VR gaming on the frame
into a pretty viable experience. To be
clear, HalfLife Alex, when you are not
tethered to a high-end PC, it's not
going to be as beautiful. But it's a
whole lot better than what I was able to
do in my hotel room before with no
setup. And when it works, it works
really, really well. On that subject,
what about 2D games in your VR headset?
Well, despite the frame using a two
generation old cell phone chip, we were
able to get many games designed for
desktop x86 CPUs running on the Steam
Frame hardware itself. And this is
largely thanks to Valve's investment in
the fast emulator for x86 or FEX. FEX is
an open-source translation layer that
allows traditional PC applications to
run on ARM processors. You can think of
it very much like Rosetta 2 for Mac,
which allowed Apple Silicon, which is
ARMbased, to run programs that were
written for Intel or x86 Max. It doesn't
work with everything, but Valve has
created a verified for Steamframe
program that will help you find
validated experiences, [music]
which at the moment only number in the
hundreds, but I have a let's call it an
evidence-based [music]
faith in St. Gay Ben that like we saw
with the Proton compatibility layer that
allows Windows games to run on Linux, we
will see exponential growth in the
coming years and FEX will eventually
reach the point where an incompatible
title feels more like the exception and
less like the rule. Also, Valve hasn't
talked about it as much, but the Leptton
translation layer to run Android apps on
Linux is also just building momentum,
and I'm very excited about that. Just
also temper your expectations for now.
Another highlight of the frame, I feel
like they just kind of keep coming here,
don't they? Is Steam OS. By shipping a
full fat Linux desktop operating system
on this thing, Valve has issued the
walled garden of competitors like Meta
and instead created a fertile breeding
ground for innovation. Don't get
intimidated, though. The familiar big
picture interface is going to be there
[music] to throw you right into your
favorite games with only a small
learning curve. It's just that Valve has
made it very clear that they want people
doing more than just VR gaming on this
thing. I'm personally planning to see
how it does for productivity, daily
driving it as my only PC for a little
while. So, make sure you're subscribed
cuz um my expectations are a little
mixed just like our experience with
performance was. Hyperoptimized
experiences run pretty well. And if it's
good on MetaQuest, it's generally going
to be good on frame or even better if it
supports fiated rendering, which is kind
of like the fiated streaming that I
explained before, but affects the render
quality from your GPU rather than the
bit rate of the stream. Now, right now,
there are not many titles that support
fiated rendering, but Valve has built
new tools that should make it much
easier for developers to implement. Good
job. Thank you, Valve. Lighter 2D
titles, including Valve's poster child,
Hades 2, also a pretty good time. But
for anything even remotely recent in the
double A and especially the AAA class,
we found the performance of the frame to
be um how do you say not even close. I
mean look, there's nothing wrong with
playing Just Cause 2 on a 150in virtual
screen, but that game is old enough to
drive a car and it was still running at
less than 60 fps at 1080p high. Now,
Valve has said they're committed to
squeezing as much performance as they
can out of this thing, but they're not
wizards, and there just isn't that much
hardware there, even if there was zero
translation layer overhead. Desktop
games, even older ones, were just not
designed around the constraints of
mobile hardware. Constraints like power
consumption. Yeah, it's time to talk
about battery life. in standalone mode.
Our best case scenario, playing a light
2D projected game netted us about an
hour and 43 minutes of play time. Not
too shabby considering it's running
directly on a computer that's bolted to
our heads. And in a seated experience,
it's no problem to hook up a true spec
cable from ltstore.com and I don't know,
maybe plug it into our upcoming battery
bank in your pocket to extend your play
time. It's just that in the worst case
scenario, playing HalfLife Alex in
standalone at 144 hertz, we got less
than an [music] hour. That kind of
sucks, but again is kind of
understandable, too. I mean, even after
all these years, gaming laptops still
haven't managed to meaningfully break
through the 1-ish hour battery glass
ceiling. So, what were we expecting
here? And Valve is working on a hot swap
battery solution for commercial users
and enthusiasts who want to go all day.
No, where we really run into trouble for
the average consumer is streaming.
Remember everything that I said before
about how immersive it is and how
magically seamlessly it works? That's
only till the battery runs out, which at
our preferred settings is going to
happen at around the hour and a half
mark. This fell way below my
expectations just based on gaming
directly on the Steam Deck versus
streaming on the Steam Deck. Like, I
thought I was going to get two, three
hours. And look, for a lot of people, an
hour and a half is as long as they're
going to want to spend in VR in one go.
But for a lot of other people, myself
included, it's not. And adding insult to
injury, we measured 0 to 100 charging
times of about three hours. Now, in
fairness to Valve, the first 95% takes
under 2 and 1/2 hours. But still, I
don't see many modern devices that break
that 3hour threshold these days. As I
said before, a cable from ltstore.com
and a power bank in your pocket will
extend your play time. But like,
wouldn't that also reduce the feeling of
wireless freedom that I praised so
eusively before? And it's weird because
the device feels full of power saving
measures like Valve's choice of
monochrome cameras for tracking and pass
through. They're fine, by the way.
Controller tracking with some help from
the onboard sensors built into them
feels as good as the Index as long as
you don't go behind your back for too
long. And the cameras can handle some
light hand tracking for gestures. But if
you were hoping to wear your headset
around the house using pass through, you
can put that thought out of your mind.
Everything from the resolution to the
stitching of the four cameras makes it a
pretty unpleasant experience. And
actually coming back to the controllers,
my feelings on those are as mixed as
anything else in this review. 40 hours
on a standard AA battery, that's
fantastic. And having a standard layout
for 2D projected games is super
convenient. But, and take this for the
personal small-handed opinion that it
is, I don't love the Steam Frame
controllers. The placement of the start
select or whatever companies are calling
them this year means that I have to
reach over the joystick resulting in
unintended button and stick presses. And
I also found that getting my finger in
the right place to access all the
buttons at once. I don't know. It's just
not particularly comfortable. A matter
made worse once you add the additional
cost ergonomics kit, which has index
style straps. I just never felt like my
hands were in quite the right spot.
There is good news. Valve offers up a
lot of flexibility. You can just pair a
regular controller to the frame for your
projected experiences. Okay, I think
that's all the official flexibility, but
still generally Steam VR is pretty
hackable and there are third party tools
that should help address use cases like
if you don't like these controllers,
swapping out to index controllers. Space
Calibrator currently supports some mixed
vendor controller setups and the
developer Heeki actually reached out
ahead of our review to say that they're
hard at work on a bunch of stuff
including by the way Linux support which
uh interesting timing Hecky since we're
on the subject of accessories. Full body
tracking was another big question mark
for me with no obvious way to tie feet
and hand trackers into the frames
tracking system. But Hecky again
highlighted a new tracker that
apparently works without any base
stations that could be very promising.
So, it looks like whatever your problem
is, the solutions will come. So, that's
the frame. Then, should you buy it?
>> You're going to have to tell them the
price first.
>> Well, let's talk about that. The Steam
Frame will be available for order on
September 14th at 10:00 a.m. Pacific.
It's going to have a similar raffle
system to the Steam Machine.
>> Yeah.
>> And it's going to cost 1,060
for the base model, which is 256 gigs,
and $1,300 for the 1 TB.
>> You know, I got to be honest with you.
It's not as bad as I was expecting given
the prices of RAM. I mean, we didn't
mention this in the review, but it's got
16 gigs of LPDDR5X.
>> It's also lower than I expected. I
thought it was going to be a slightly
higherend display.
>> I feel like what we're seeing here is
just like how the Steam Machine was
clearly not priced to disrupt the
market. If anything, it was priced to
protect Valve's ongoing interest as
potential price increases continue to
happen. The Steam Frame is priced for
adoption. It's priced to [music]
put this in the hands of as many people
as possible to incentivize ongoing
development of in the long term the
Steam OS platform, the FEX translation
layer and all of these software
initiatives that are going to help Valve
sell buckets and buckets of games, not
necessarily for the Steam frame, but for
future VR headsets that are also running
ARM processors.
>> Well, the sky's is the limit with FEX.
if they can get x86 games on mobile
devices, if they can start to work on
that market, who knows where they can
possibly take Steam.
>> So, as much as it's a high price, I feel
like this is the closest that we're
going to get to like a like a console
subsidized price. I think that like with
the Steam Deck, Valve did go pretty
aggressive here.
>> And it's not that much more expensive
than a console is. [laughter]
That's the world we live in.
>> I hate that that's true. One thing that
sucks though is that the ergonomics kit
is a cost additional thing. It's $60.
That includes the knuckle straps. That
includes the top strap and the small
nose nose skirt.
>> Yeah,
>> but it's a must buy. You have to get it.
It is so much better with the top strap
for comfort. And if you don't have the
knuckle straps, you can't do the full
grip open close.
>> I think everyone who tried the steam
frame complained about the comfort
>> until we put the top strap on. Yeah, I
like having the battery in the back for
the weight balance, but then this hard
plate, like I think you were saying,
means that unless you have exactly the
right head shape, the pressure can be a
little bit off.
>> Yeah, it can either put more pressure on
the outside or if you have more of a
sharp head, it could be a little bit
more on the inside. Like the odds of it
being exactly the shape of your head.
Pretty slim. So, by not having to
tighten it as much and being able to
rely on the head strap to bear some of
that weight makes a [snorts] huge
difference. With that said, nothing
Valve can do can take away the weight of
the battery.
>> And compared to something like a big
screen Beyond 2, which I don't think
you've tried.
>> I have not.
>> It's a tough comparison. They're such
different products
>> and very different pricing categories.
Just the goggles are the same price as
this, but then you got your lighouses,
your controllers, everything else you
need, and then you're into an entirely
different pricing category. This is
true, but it has an OLED display
>> and zero zero skirt, so full immersion.
And while I actually complained a little
bit about the swampy eye feeling of the
big screen beyond cuz it's so sealed in
there, I actually get the opposite
effect with the frame. The cooling fans
actually run over my eyes a little bit
and I get a little bit of a dry eye
effect. So, this is going to just come
down to would you rather have the drag
of a battery on your head or would you
rather have the drag of a cord pulling
on you and swampy versus dry eye? I
don't know. And if you don't want wire,
you could go with the Metaquest. I found
in standalone experiences, I would be
pretty hardressed to tell the difference
in fidelity. The screens are pretty
close uh in terms of resolution and
performance.
>> Unfortunately,
>> uh this is more performant and there's
way more flexibility. The big difference
is the wireless is universes ahead than
the meta one. The meta one I've never
had a great time at home at the office
making wireless work flawlessly.
>> The copium of Meta fanboys do they
exist? Talking about how the Metquest 3
line is you never talk about how great
the MetaQuest 3 is for PC VR. Guys, when
you've tried this, you'll get why we're
not that excited about that. The Medic
Quest has the huge advantage of insane
amount of subsidization.
>> Yes.
>> The fact that it's what, $600?
>> There's more than one headset that's in
such a different price category that
it's hard to ignore. Like the PSVR2, I
know you're not a big fan of that
headset, [music] but you can get them
for a few hundred Canadian dollars.
>> They're so cheap. It's just those
Fresnel lenses cost chromatic
aberration. Like, I hadn't used it
before working on this review, and I
would describe it as mostly unplayable
after getting used to this.
>> If you've never seen this before,
they're not that bad. And the OLED
contrast
is pretty nice. On the subject of the
PSVR, even though you're a lifelong
PlayStation fanboy who's probably tried
just about every Sony accessory, like
ever for the PlayStation.
>> Yeah, probably.
>> You never tried a PSVR 2 before you were
working on this review. Is it that
you're just not interested in VR? Is it
the price point? Does this change
anything for you? Are you sold now? I've
never gone into VR because I've been
waiting for this big threshold moment
where I'm like, "Oh, yeah. I'm going to
put it on and I'm just totally
immersed." Is this it?
>> No. Every single time I put on a VR
headset, I'm like,
>> "Oh, it's like I can see the screen door
and it's I can see the the fakeness of
it and it's very good." And the setup
was so nice cuz that's a big blocker for
me, too. I don't want to install
lighouses. I don't want to like tinker
with things to make it work. This just
worked, but it still has that
artificiality that I think the promise
of VR isn't delivering on yet.
>> Does this at least get you excited for
the trajectory?
>> Absolutely. And if it can continue to be
this simple to get working and set up,
we are heading in the right direction.
>> If I could give you this with an OLED
tomorrow,
>> I'd pay a lot of money for that.
>> I can't. [laughter]
>> Dang it.
>> Yeah. And I don't know how long it's
going to take Valve to do it. I mean
their cadence is what 7 to 10 years
between hardware releases and that
assumes we will ever get a third.
>> Do you want to talk about stereoscopic
content?
>> Honestly, not really. I'm I'm as much of
a 3D guy as I think anyone is these
days, but there's so little content
available for it that you can watch 3D
movies. Uh, ironically, Big Screen's app
is actually a really great experience on
third party headsets
>> for Yeah. You can like sit in a theater
kind of and watch 2D content or you can
watch 3D content through it. It's very
cool. Uh, but I just in the limited
amount of time we had, I just didn't
really get into it.
>> Do you think this is enough to get you
to switch from your big screen beyond to
this?
>> I'm going to be honest with you. I went
back to my index again.
>> What?
>> It's just so convenient. I have a
multi-user household and sometimes I
have friends over and we are doing mixed
couch and VR experiences and it just I
can't have silicone gasket switching all
the time.
>> That's right.
>> And this
is everything that's great about the
Index just about but in an even more
convenient package and there's no
question that this is going to be my
go-to. There are some things that I'd
love to see Valve improve. I don't love
how little consideration they give to
travel. Never mind that it doesn't come
with a carrying case like the Vision
Pro. I'll forgive that at the much lower
price point. It doesn't even have any
kind of meaningful lens blocker. I'm
going to have to like 3D print
something. And because the lenses,
there's no real way to fix them if they
get broken. But for all my complaints
and there were a lot cuz it's like kind
of my job. I think this is the best
package on the market.
>> It's hard to argue with that. Just like
it's hard to argue with our sponsor,
>> Threat Locker. With AI deploying into
the workplace, new vulnerabilities and
exploits being discovered daily, and the
speed in which the cyber security
landscape is changing, it's important to
continue to stay on top of how you can
keep your business secure. That's where
Threat Locker and their flagship event,
Zero Trust World, come in. At Zero Trust
World, there will be hands-on labs, deep
dives into today's most pressing topics,
and plenty of opportunities to connect
and learn from other cyber security
professionals. We've gotten to attend
and speak at zero trust world and the
conference continues to grow every year.
Also, the sessions are eligible for
continuing education credits and
attendees will leave with the knowledge
and skills needed to implement zero
trust in their organization. Did I
mention hacking labs? Attendees receive
firsthand experience deploying and going
through the path of an attack,
understanding how these exploits work
and how to prevent them. Learn more
about zero trust world and secure your
ticket at the link in the description.
If you guys enjoyed this video, why not
check out the review of the Big Screen
Beyond 2? It is an equally valid but
very different product. Try that. It's
great for forever alone.
It's perfect.